so I had dinner with Tom Cruise like  years ago after he did that thing out  out of the building  [Music]  in London and and we all had dinner  together and so I I kind of cornered him  and I said hey tell me about this like  I'm afraid of heights how did you do  this thing and he goes oh I you know  because he really wanted to talk about  it he said I've been dreaming of this  shot for 15 years of this sequence and  finally I had a chance to do it and he  goes well so how did it come to pass and  he goes okay okay so I go to the safety  guy I tell him that's what I'm going to  do this is what I'm going to explain the  whole the whole the whole gag to him  right  a safety guy  says you can't do that  because that's too dangerous and I'm  like uh-huh and he goes  so I get another safety guy  that was it